there are the images of her arriving at
downing street a few moments ago
alongside her husband uh that is richard
radcliffe who became very well known in
the campaign for her release of course
and her daughter
little gabriella
well we can go live to westminster our
political correspondent tamara cohen is
there for us now tomorrow this has the
potential to be a fairly awkward meeting
doesn't it not least because uh nazanin
zagari radcliffe was not terribly
complimentary about the efforts from
successive foreign secretaries in
securing her release of which boris
johnson was one
that's right sam nazanin meeting boris
johnson for the first time of course
after six years held in captivity in
iran meeting him with richard and her
daughter gabriella it's a private
meeting so we won't be told exactly what
they discussed but of course we heard
from nazanin just days after her release
a little less than two months ago when
she gave a press release in parliament
and very much gave the impression that
this wouldn't be a kind of thank you
very much prime minister let's move on
she was very clear in that meeting even
though her husband richard and her local
mp chilip sadiq who went with her today
thanked liz truss and the government for
their efforts to secure her release she
said it shouldn't have taken six years
and shouldn't have taken the efforts of
five foreign secretaries to get to this
point and so i can imagine she will be
asking the prime minister more about
whether it should have been quicker when
they meet today
downing streets say the prime minister
has been keen to meet her since her
release but of course was waiting for
her to take the time to decide when it
was right she's of course been
making up lost time with her family and
with her daughter gabriella who's now
almost eight years old and of course
spent six years without her mother so
it's taken a bit of time to get to this
point but nazanin made very clear at
that press conference when she talked
about her cruel treatment in iran and
how it would haunt her for years to come
that she wants to see more action to
prevent this happening again she was
released with another british iranian
anusha ashuri who is not here today but
the prime minister keen to meet him as
well and she raised the case of
a third person murad tabaz an elderly
british american iranian national who is
still in iran it had been hoped that he
would be released too but he is still in
prison so we expect that will be raised
too and in a statement from her local mp
chilip siddique she said that it's right
that that nazanin hears directly from
the prime minister why it took so long
to get her released as you say sam a bit
of awkward history here because when
boris johnson was foreign secretary back
in 2017 he told a committee of mps this
was about a year into her detention
there when it was hoped she might be
released he said that she had been in
iran training journalists which her
family have always maintained that she
was on holiday visiting her parents he
was very much criticized there were
calls for him to resign and he ended up
apologizing for the anguish and distress
he caused and correcting the record to
say that he had made a mistake when
downing street were asked today whether
he would be apologizing to her today
they said as they have said before that
it was iran's responsibility for holding
her captive but that he had previously
apologized for those comments and
richard radcliffe of course has
campaigned in a very high profile way
for her release and met boris johnson in
the past when he was doing that
campaigning
yes indeed they said he wanted to retire
from his position as a campaign manager
for her release tamara thank you very
much